President Biden has let 6.2 million
illegal aliens into the United States
according to data from the Congressional
budget office Biden l in 1.2 million
illegal aliens in the first year then
upped it to 2.7 million in the second
year and then hit a whopping 3.3 million
this past year just through October
which means the final number for last
year will inevitably M be much much
higher if the illegals that Biden alone
let in over just 3 years were form their
own state it would be the 18th most
populous state in the Union a state
formed of just Joe Biden's illegal
aliens would be 7% larger than Wyoming
Vermont Alaska North Dakota South Dakota
Delaware and Rhode Island combined we
are witnessing an historic illegal
invasion of our ostensibly Sovereign
Nation but whereas most invasions in
history have been hostile in this case
this illegal invasion is being conducted
with the approval and encouragement of
the president of the United States and
his entire Administration I'm Michael
nolles this is the Michael nlls
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the show a new Amazon
kids
cartoon is promoting Satan and I don't
mean that in just an
implicit subliminal message kind of way
I mean that's just the point of the show
it's called hasp been hotel we'll get to
that in a second first though while
Biden is actively encouraging the
largest Invasion ever of our
country Greg Abbott down in Texas the
governor there is taking matters into
his own hands so he has notified the
president that the federal government
quote has broken the compact between the
United States and the states uh the
executive the president has a
constitutional duty to enforce federal
laws protecting States including
immigration laws that are on the books
right now and Biden has refused to do
that and uh so Governor Abbott's going
to take matters into his own hands now
you know that Governor Abbott had
already been building a very modest
amount border fencing to try to stop the
flow of illegal migrants the Biden
Administration would then go in they
would send border patrol agents to cut
down the border fencing that had been
erected by the Texas National Guard so
so already you've got the Biden
Administration sending in troops to open
up the border to allow more illegal
aliens to flow into the
country uh the state of Texas then tries
to put up more border fence they they
sue the Biden Administration it goes all
the way up to the Supreme Court and the
Supreme Court in a 5-4 decision says no
Biden has the right to tear down Texas's
border protections and to allow an
invasion to come into Texas this
obviously the courts conservatives sided
with Texas the Court's liberals plus
chief justice Roberts plus Amy Barrett
I'm sorry to say uh sided with the libs
and said no no Biden can go destroy
Texas's border we need more illegals
here uh so abbit lists all of these
sorts of things and then says under
President Biden's Lawless border
policies more than 6 million illegal
immigrants have crossed our Southern
Border in just three years James Madison
Alexander Hamilton and other Visionaries
who wrote the US Constitution foresaw
that states should not be left to the
mercy of a lawless president who does
nothing to stop external threats like
cartels smuggling millions of illegal
immigrants across the border that is why
the framers included both article 4
section 4 which promises that the
federal government shall protect each
state against Invasion Article 1 Section
10 Clause 3 which acknowledges the
state's Sovereign interest in protecting
their borders uh the failure of the
Biden Administration to fulfill these
duties which reserves the right of
self-defense has led Texas to take
matters into their own hands I have
already declared an invasion under
Article 1 Section 10 Clause 3 to invoke
Texas's constitutional authority to
defend and protect itself it goes on
those are the highlights brilliant move
by Abbott here because what Abbott
is bringing to the center stage is not a
battle between State's rights and the
federal government
exactly he's he's bringing to light a a
constitutional crisis he's saying not
just that certain powers are reserved to
the states and certain powers are are
given to the federal government he's
saying when the federal government does
not execute the law as the Constitution
requires it to do then the Constitution
gives the states this particular right
to defend against an
invasion so it's not some some ambiguous
matter you know a state constitution
versus the Federal Constitution it it's
just spelled out in the Constitution and
in the writing of our family fathers and
the framers of our constitution so you
know you have an issue Joe Biden take it
up with the Constitution this will very
possibly Force this back into the
Supreme Court especially as other
Governors sign on Florida Governor Ronda
santis has just come out very very
strongly said we back Texas in in this
move a number of other Republican
Governors have as well this is brilliant
it's not only just it's not only the
right thing to do because it's wrong to
allow a a mass invasion of foreigners to
take over the political order of a
country when the citizens have no say in
that it's not only just it's not only
legally persuasive you just heard the
arguments they're a hell of a lot better
than Joe Biden's arguments but the key
here is that it's politically brilliant
what are Joe Biden's options Joe Biden
has two options now Joe Biden can back
down after just winning at the Supreme
Court he can back down and allow the
Texas National Guard to build some kind
of border fencing which will still allow
a lot of illegal immigrants to come
through but not quite as many or Joe
Biden can send federal troops to remove
Texas National Guard troops from The
Bard
and to remove any kind of border fencing
and to actively open up a path for an
invasion of foreign Nationals into the
country which looks worse for Biden I
don't know I mean it's that's pretty
crazy to use federal troops to encourage
an invasion because Biden has been doing
this from the beginning in a subtle way
he said surge come to the Border please
and then he'll say I never said that
what are you talking about no no I don't
we are enforcing border policy no no we
are are stopping illegal immigration
surge come here come on Jack we got
plenty of hairy leg Corn Pops up here
just bring bring everyone come on
cartels but if if if Biden sends federal
troops to remove Texas National Guard
troops to open up the
border that argument goes out the window
not even the Democrats are so braz and
they can't do that with a straight
face and
coincidentally immigration is the big
issue the The Establishment media
downplay this but this has been the
primary issue to motivate conservative
and Centrist and independent and normal
voters in the West for the better part
of a decade now Mass migration is what
brexit was about Mass migration is is
what right-wing winds and right-wing
movements
in Spain Germany Italy Hungary Poland
throughout the West have been about
Donald Trump's campaign in 2016 was
about how Mexico is sending rapists and
murderers and I suppose some good people
to the border and we're going to stop it
and build a big beautiful wall and make
Mexico pay for it and Deport all of the
people who shouldn't be
here and he did a pretty good job on it
actually for the first year or two of
his presidency and then the cartels
realized that the rest of the political
establishment was going to sty him so
immigration rose up again but for the
first part it worked pretty well and
even if it didn't work at all that is
what motivated the voters this is a
major major winning issue for
conservatives and my favorite kind of
political operations or when you only
leave your opponent with bad options
that's exactly what governor Abbott has
done here and yet Democrats
say that it is us not the people sending
in the troops to open the border to
flood the country with with foreigners
no no no it is us we conservatives who
want to defend even the basic rule of
law we are the threat to democracy but
Trump said this is not typical he is
exactly right this is not a typical
election and there's a massive effort to
normalize this you see the New York
Times column say well the Trump people
have a case you see the head of JP
Morgan Chase the largest bank in the
United States saying well they they're
right about some things you see
reporters with uh Jason Miller in the
Fort De mo hotel reminds me of a bunch
of German reporters in some Munich uh
bar in 1935 saying hey Goring he was an
entertaining guy I tell you what he had
some great stories nothing is normal
about this at all and you watched his
speech last night it was completely
unhinged and what I am obsessed with is
stop treating him like he is a normal
candidate that this is some kind of Bobo
Mitt Romney this is really not stop
treating Trump like he's normal three
big points in carville's ranti here and
James Carville is a major figure among
the Democrat political class first point
Trump's a
Nazi could you imagine at a bar in
Munich with the Nazis it's just like
that he's a Nazi wow really brilliant
you're you're you're making me see
Donald Trump in a whole new and
interesting light wow what brilliant
commentary James Carville good grief uh
that one you can dismiss that second one
we got to stop treating Trump like he's
normal he's not normal we got to stop
treating him like he's
normal the man was the president of the
United
States already he's already been the
president he's normalized he's normal
the man has been a major American public
figure for over 40
years the man endorsed Mitt Romney that
candidate who you suddenly have a
strange new respect for and that was a
big to-do when he did that in 2012 and
he was already the president he's he's
normal if he's not normal then what is
these are the people who say that
chopping off the genitals of a little
child that's perfectly normal but the
man who was already president the
somewhat slightly more right-wing
Republican but basically just a
republican that's totally abnormal but
but he gives away the game because what
does he say there at the end he said
he's not a normal Republican like Mitt
Romney and Bob Dole what do Mitt Romney
and Bob Dole have in common that
distinguishes them from Donald Trump
they lost that's look I I like Bob Dole
but that's it that's what they mean when
when the Democrats promote normal
Republicans they promote people who lose
because in the normal operation of
events in Democrats Minds Republicans
are supposed to lose because they're
wrong supposed to present a facade of
opposition a simulacrum of real
opposition and political choice but then
at when push comes to shove at The
crucial moment they're supposed to lose
John McCain at The crucial moment he's
supposed to vote to support Obamacare at
the at the crucial moment they're
supposed to just cave and defend Liz
Cheney she might vote with Trump a lot
of the time but at The crucial moment
when political power is really in play
she's got a side with Nancy Pelosi
that's that's normal Mitt Romney he's
yeah nominate him and he's going to go
talk about cutting taxes and then then
the Democrats are going to call him a
Nazi and then he's going to lose and
then they'll like him
again that's that's what's supposed to
be what's abnormal about Trump is that
he won when he wasn't supposed to and he
won with a group of Voters who were not
supposed to be in powered the deplorable
irredeemables and he won on an issue
that you are absolutely never supposed
to talk about that is the mass migration
now let's call it like Abbott does an
invasion of foreigners into this country
to give Democrats and liberals permanent
political power you are you are under no
circumstances allowed to criticize that
that's that's a big threat to our
democracy suggesting that we the
American people ought to still have a
say on how our government is run huge
unacceptable threat to our democracy now
things are a little up in the air when
the economy and politics is up in the
air you're probably going to want some
tangible assets you're going to want to
check out Birch gold right now text
nolles to 98 9898 as we head toward a
presidential election in November there
is one thing you can be sure of 2024
will be a tumultuous year how will your
hard-earned savings fair you're already
seeing the impacts of inflation at the
pump and the grocery store the dollar
continues to lose its buying power
faster than wages increase how are you
protecting your savings consider
diversifying into gold from Birch gold
group for decades gold has been the
choice of investors and central banks to
hedge against inflation if you have an
IRA or 401K from a previous employer
that is just Gathering dust call Birch
gold they will help you convert it into
an IRA in Gold you won't pay a penny out
of pocket they will simply convert that
401k into physical gold which unlike
digital currency can't be tampered with
just text Nes kwes to 98 9898 and Birch
gold will send you a free info kit today
with an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau thousands of satisfied
customers and the exclusive gold company
of the daily wire for the past seven
years you can trust Birch gold to text n
canw to 98 9898 to claim your free info
kit that is NES canw to 98 9898 to
secure your savings now so you got the
Democrats huffing and puffing this isn't
normal trumps a not see same old stuff
you've heard
forever then you turn to the ostensibly
conservative TV channel and they're
going after Trump too how would you feel
if Trump wins the nomination 53% of
Republicans will be very satisfied but
here's the problem for the former
president according to our voter
analysis 35% of Republicans said they
would not vote for Donald Trump and in a
political article uh they say with their
analysis 43% of Nikki Haley voters
yesterday would vote for Joe Biden well
43 so he'd get what the rest of that
which is a lot so that's Fox News
ostensibly the conservative
Channel giving the same coverage that
the Democrats are giving Donald Trump
he's gonna he's he's abnormal a huge
portion of Republicans aren't going to
vote for him this is unprecedented we
you know Trump he's bound to
lose I don't believe it I don't believe
it and the reason I don't believe this
type of analysis that we're all of a
sudden hearing that Trump is the
presumptive nominee the reason that I
don't believe that there's a huge chunk
of Republicans who under no
circumstances will vote for Trump is
they voted for him in 2016 when that was
a much riskier
Endeavor that's why because in 2016 when
we were told and we didn't have any
political data to show that Trump wasn't
a Nazi we were told he's Hitler he's
going to tear the country apart it'll be
a constitutional crisis he's the most
evil man that's ever run for
president there was the huge at least in
the media never Trump movement people
who actually came out these Republicans
they said I will never I will never
under any circumstances ever vote for
Trump and then the vast majority of them
said okay well maybe I'll vote for Trump
under some circumstances okay that was
that was the chance for a large portion
of the GOP to not vote for Trump and
they failed thankfully and and Trump
became president and he was quite good
he didn't he didn't manage to go all the
distance on his campaign promises he
only had one term certain things he did
were not wonderful and perfect but
overall he was the best most
conservative president of my life time
it's not even
close and so you you really think if
never Trump flopped in 2016 when it had
all the wind in its sails you think it's
going to succeed this time I just don't
bite I'm not saying Trump's guaranteed
to win the election I'm just saying the
notion that 35 % of Republicans are not
going to vote for him is crazy why would
why would Fox push this kind of coverage
oh I don't know maybe because Trump cost
Fox $800 billion in that Dominion
settlement because Trump pointed out
that the election seemed a bit rigged
and uh Fox News settled out of court
with people who brought defamation suits
about that that might be part of it
maybe because there are extremely
establishment Republicans who sit on the
Fox News board at best there're also
just liberal Democrats who help run Fox
News I don't I know maybe it's because
Fox News for goodness sakes has has
aired segments promoting in children
okay the the notion that that this TV
channel would represent conservatives be
able to speak with expert analysis on on
the conservative base it's just silly
and that this is something that that
Trump has done in his entire National
political career he's exposed the
silliness he's he's exposed the
shallowness he's exposed the the falsity
of all these people who purport to speak
for the American people and defend
American democracy and and represent
what is normal they are not normal the
Beltway is not normal Joe Biden flooding
the country with foreigners is not
normal is not normal these people who
have control over the media and over the
image that is projected toward the
American people they are totally bizarre
they represent extremely Fringe views
that are not at all popular you know
what's normal the irredeemable
deplorable in the middle of the country
and fly over country who doesn't think
that 6 million foreigners should flood
into his country and diminish his
political rights over the course of
three years that's the normal that's the
actual normal guy and whether he
succeeds or fails Trump represents that
guy I'm not I'm not saying Trump's going
to win I'm not saying the Trump
movement's going to win I'm not saying
that that guy that deplorable guy in the
middle of the country is going to have
the last laugh over the Beltway lunatic
I'm just saying that that's where the
battle lines are and you want to you
want to ask me who's normal and who's
abnormal it's not even close there is no
competition now speaking of the
abnormality of our ruling political
class and Joe
Biden Joe Biden is leaning in on
abortion the Republicans are leaning in
on immigration Joe Biden and the
Democrats are leaning in on abortion
they just aired an ad about the awful
dire terrible consequences for women
of the Supreme Court's decision to stop
pretending that there's a constitutional
right to slaughter 800,000 babies a year
I'm an OBGYN in Texas and a mother of
three wonderful children having this
beautiful messy chaotic but wonderful
family it's the joy of my life I never
thought that I would need an abortion
for a planned pregnancy but I did 2
years ago I became pregnant with a baby
I desperately wanted at a routine
ultrasound I learned that the fetus
would have a fatal condition and that
there was absolutely no chance of
survival in Texas you are forced to
carry that pregnancy and that is because
of Donald Trump overturning roie Wade
the choice was completely taken away I
was to continue my pregnancy putting my
life at risk it's every woman's worst
nightmare and it was absolutely
unbearable we need leaders that will
protect our rights and not take them
away and that's Joe Biden and kamla
Harris I'm Joe Biden and I approve this
message okay if what she said were true
that would be pretty compelling right
I'm a mom I'm not just one of the uh
typical abortion users I'm not just
someone who has no regard for babies and
doesn't want to face any consequences
from her actions and wants to divorce
the ends of sex sex no no I'm a mom I
wanted this kid but my kid had this this
condition and there was a 0% chance that
the kid would survive and it put my life
at risk but because of Donald Trump and
then the Texas Republicans don't forget
Donald Trump didn't Outlaw abortion in
America he appointed judges who
recognize that there's no right to
abortion anywhere certainly not in the
Constitution and left the issue up to
the states and because of
Texas they wanted me to carry my baby to
term they wouldn't even let me murder my
baby and that risked my
life if the premise were true I guess
her argument would be somewhat
compelling the problem is if my aunt had
she'd be my uncle the problem is if
my Grandma had Wheels she'd be a wagon
problem is the premise isn't true This
Woman's name is Dr Austin Denard she's
an
obgyn I wonder if she is an abortionist
herself as a number of OBG WS are I
don't know I have no idea just kind of
wondering the woman is this F
fanatically pro-abortion that she would
become the face of the pro-abortion
movement for the president of the United
States raises questions about her
involvement with the issue uh she
learned that her baby very sadly had a
condition called
anany uh which is which is
fatal so all that stuff might be true
the part that's not true is that it
risked her life it didn't an inphy does
not cause life-threatening
complications and furthermore Texas
allows for abortions when the mother
faces complications that could impact
her health not even that will very
likely kill her that could impact her
health Heth so every political
point the the medical Point she makes
and then all the political points
completely fake news there was a 2019
study conducted by the journal of
clinical medicine research of
anencephalic pregnancies uh that are not
aborted right that that do not end up
with a mother killing her child as this
woman wanted to do and they found that
not one of them not one of these 28
pregnancies resulted in maternal deaths
any complications that did occur were
were treated
is just totally fake and the libs always
have to do this the libs always have to
lie about part of it because the the
reality if this woman came out and
actually told the truth which is uh I
got pregnant something very sad happened
and so I wanted to take the decision
into my own hands and kill my baby uh
rather than just waiting it out a little
bit and and uh allowing my child to live
as long as he could before he very
likely would die uh rather than that you
had to say I was going to die you you
weren't you wouldn't and the fact that
they have to lie about this to to give a
moral justification for what they want
to do is the proof that they know that
as things stand in reality there is no
moral justification whatsoever now we
turn from morality to money we got to
talk about American financing right now
go to americanfinancing.net it's 2024
and a lot of us are trying to get our
finances in order there is some great
news for homeowners interest rates have
dropped down to the fives that's a l lot
lower than where they were last year if
you have been buried in highin credit
card debt now is the time to Break Free
with American financing American
financing can help you access the cash
in your home to pay off your high
interest debt last year their salary
based mortgage consultants helped
customers save an average of $854 a
month that is like giving yourself a
$10,000 raise what way to start the new
year if you start today you may be able
to delay two mortgage payments call
American financing today at
4711 that is
8665695076
334 nmls consumer access.org APR for
rates in the five stars at 6.27 5% for
well-qualified borrowers call 800
685-5627 with over one year of
unparalleled output his contributions
have set new standards and remained
unmatched by any other platform
dailywire plus now has a vast array of
exclusive Jordan Peterson content
offering hundreds of hours of
captivating content you won't find
anywhere else Jordan has created
thought-provoking works that reshape
your perspective on life such as his
series vision and Destiny marriage and
monsters and dragons and men and this
and that and there's so many ANS I don't
even know where one show begins and
another one ends Additionally you can
immerse yourself in his Spiritual Works
including logos and literacy and
Jordan's groundbreaking series on the
book of Exodus that's only the beginning
I have not even mentioned his Beyond
order lecture series well now I have I
guess or his extensive Archive of
lectures and podcasts plus there's even
more new exclusive content on the
horizon become a dailywire plus member
and embark on an unforgettable
experience that will fuel your thirst
for knowledge and Inspire personal
growth like never before go to
dailywire.com subscribe to become a
member
today
the Democrat position on abortion which
is an issue they're leaning into is not
only heinous and wrong and evil and
deeply
unjust it's also pretty
unpopular not the position that they
pretend to hold where they say oh I I
love babies I would never want to kill
my baby but I just you know in certain
very rare cases when a threat to my life
is presenting itself then I might
tragically have to accept it that's not
the Democrat view on abortion they are
lying when they say say that you want to
know what the Democrat view on abortion
is they they they just told us in a new
Marist poll the Democrat view on
abortion is
that when presented with a Down Syndrome
baby you know you do a little test while
the baby's in the womb they say oh your
baby's going to have Down
syndrome most Democrats want to murder
that
baby most of
them I'll the question I'll give it to
you straight so you don't think I'm
hiding anything here do you strongly
support support oppose or strongly
oppose abortion because the child will
be born with Down Syndrome 56% of Dems
say they support those abortions only
42% oppose not even close which
means that most Democrats want to
genocide people not all people
with mental retardation but actually a
specific group of people who can be
extremely high functioning who according
to every social scientific statistic
will report higher levels of happiness
certainly than
Democrats they say we got to murder
those people and you know the craziest
part of
all they will attack me for just using
the word it occurs to me I they
certainly will attack me there will
probably be a clip from this segment
from some leftwing Outlet saying Michael
nolles used the word mental retardation
in a precise and clinical sense yeah yes
that's true I used words clearly to
express something uh that exists in the
world you want to murder these people
are you kidding me and they'll do it
with a straight face these are the
people who if you eat meat they will say
oh you're so heartless you you would
kill a cow just to make you a
hamburger yeah you would murder someone
for having some mental problems you
would murder them a little baby actually
not even like an adult who you know
commits a crime or something you would
you actually wouldn't kill the adults
who commit the crimes you would kill the
little baby because he doesn't have
quite as many eyq points as you wish he
would go even further ask a ask one of
these Democrats what they think about
puppies you say Hey you think it's wrong
to kick a puppy of course it's wrong to
kick a what kind of Heartless cruel
monster would kick a puppy okay what do
you think about babies with some mental
problems oh yeah we got to murder them
all kill them all of course could you
imagine how inconvenient they would be
they might not be exactly how you want
they might have a a slight imperfection
unlike all of us we're just totally
perfect right oh yes we're so are you
kidding
me totally sick stuff and so I will
Dismount my high horse for a second and
move away from the moral part of this
and just focus on the political part
this is a complete loser for Democrats
the abortion issue framed in the the
real way that it really uh is presented
in the world is a huge loser for
Democrats huge winner for
republicans in all cases but especially
this hey the the most vulnerable person
that you could possibly imagine not just
a person but a little baby not just a
little baby but a little baby with
particular challenges um you want to
murder that person oh yeah we absolutely
do that is that is as Gastly a political
position as anyone could
possibly
hold and you know that the squish
Republicans are going to run away from
this oh we don't want to talk about
abortion abortion no it's a Democrats
win on abortion no they don't win on
this I should hope they don't win on if
Democrats win on this if if most
Americans hold the view that most
Democrats hold which is that we should
kill mentally babies we should
murder mentally people because
they have no value at all then forget
then forget Democratic politics I guess
then the country's totally lost and
whatever let's go keep our heads down
before the end times I don't think most
Americans feel that way I don't think so
at least not yet lean into this issue
it's the right thing to do because these
people on the left are actually
genocidal but it's also going to be a
political winner it's a winner if people
have courage to talk about it the lib
libs are not just implicitly embracing
evil they are now very explicitly
promoting it there's a show that's been
making the rounds on social media it's
called hasbin Hotel it's a cartoon it's
a kids cartoon that you can get on
Amazon Prime right now and it's a
defense of the
[Music]
devil once upon a time there was a
glowing City protected by Golden Gates
known as Heaven it was ruled by beings
of pure light angels that worship good
and shielded all from Evil Lucifer was
one of these angels He was a dreamer
with Fantastical ideas for all of
creation but he was seen as a
troublemaker by the Elders of Heaven for
they felt his way of thinking was
dangerous to the order of their world so
he watched as the Angels began to expand
the universe in their ways from the dust
of Earth they created Adam and Lilith
equals as the first of mankind but
despite this
so a lot of people are going to wonder
Lilith who's Lilith I know Adam and Eve
Who's Lilith Lilith is a figure from
Jewish folklore and so it Lilith is not
a figure from scripture Lilith is not a
figure a figure from church tradition
but Lilith appears in the Babylonian
talmud and some other Jewish folklore
and she's presented as the first wife of
Adam who refused to submit to Adam um so
already you're seeing a fairly I mean
you've seen it from the beginning of a
fairly novel take on uh the uh creation
story it goes on but despite this Adam
demanded control and Lilith refused to
submit to his will she fled the garden
drawn in by her Fierce Independence
Lucifer found her and the two rebellious
dreamers fell deeply in love together
they wished to share the magic of Free
Will with Humanity offering the fruit of
knowledge to Adam's new bride Eve who
gladly accepted but this gift came with
a curse for with this single act of
Disobedience evil finally found its way
into Earth with it a new Realm of
Darkness and sin and the order Heaven
had worked to maintain was shattered as
punishment for their Reckless act Heaven
cast Lucifer and his love into the dark
pit he had created never allowing him to
see the good that came from Humanity
so notice this little word they sneak in
there they say uh Lucifer and his love
but of course Lucifer cannot love anyone
the the traditional understanding of
this is that a love is willing the good
of the other person uh so Fulton Sheen
Archbishop Fulton Sheen has a a great
distinction between love and sex right
love is
about uh another person and about uh
some outside even outside of you and the
other person and it's about in as much
as it is about a person it's about the
whole person right love
gives sex the way we talk about sex
these days you know hookup cultures say
is purely about the self in as much as
it's about another person it's just
about using that other person's body to
gratify the self it's about
instrumentalizing people uh CS Lewis
talks about this in the screw tape
letters when uh human beings talk about
desire and love it's about
a a desire for another person when the
demons talk about desire and love it's
about a desire to use the other person
to devour him it's about always coming
back to the self so there's no there's
no love in the traditional understanding
of Lucifer uh then you know these these
poor hapless little Rebels you know
they're cast and they don't get to see
the good that came out of their evil but
the traditional understanding is and the
true understanding is that the Garden of
Eden was perfect was totally perfect and
sin and death pervade the world because
man is tempted by Adam and abuses his
free will this this version of Lucifer
is more like a Promethean view of
Lucifer this this view of Lucifer is
that Lucifer actually helps man to
achieve his true potential and so much
more good came out of it though there
was a little bit of evil too you know
life's kind of messy man uh keep going
only the cruel and the wicked ashamed
Lucifer lost his will to dream but
Lilith thrived empowering demonkind with
her voice and her songs and as the
numbers of Hell grew so did its power
okay you you get it here what's funny
from the very beginning they say Lilith
was an equal with Adam but it but Eve is
presented in a way as an equal with Adam
too because Eve is taken from Adam's Rib
so not from his head she's not above
Adam not from his foot she's not below
Adam is from his rib though they have
different roles and they're
complimentary and so she does submit to
Adam I mean you hear this in Genesis
chter 3 when they're about to leave the
Garden of Eden and Adam is called on to
love Eve here though you get a mixture
of Satanism and feminism and the the
show is listed as being for mature
audiences but do you really think kids
aren't going to watch that show I mean I
remember when I was a kid South Park was
for mature
audiences kids loved South Park myself
included and though there's some naughty
stuff in South Park relative to the rest
of the culture it's not so bad because
South Park has a broadly normal and
conservative message this uh not so much
so the the r is up in arms and
everyone's clutching their pearls and
everyone's so shocked can you believe
what the culture has come to that they
would do this I'm not shocked at all
none of this is surprising none of this
is new none of this is original this is
the same thing you see in the first
pages of solinsky's Rules for Radicals
solinsky's Rules for Radicals the first
edition has just after the dedication an
acknowledgement uh to Lucifer that first
Rebel who lost heaven but won himself a
kingdom so Linsky is saying I'm modeling
my activism and solinsky's left-wing
activism is is the kind of community
organizing that directly inspired
Hillary Clinton she wrote letters to
solinsky that inspired Barack Obama that
inspired the modern Democrat Party he he
says my leftist
activism is Satanism is
luciferianism is we our inspiration is
not God our in Inspiration is not our
Lord Jesus Christ Our inspiration is the
devil and Amazon says yeah that what he
said okay yeah that's what we've been
seeing from the beginning leftism from
the
beginning has been a rebellion against
God leftism the term comes from the
National Assembly during the French
Revolution when the people on the right
of the Assembly Hall supported the
church and the king and the people on
the left of the Assembly Hall opposed
the church and the legitimate
Authority it's always been about that
man it goes all the way back to the
Garden of Eden when men say ye shall be
his Gods that's what that's what it goes
back to it goes back to the Tower of
Babel when men tried to become higher
than God and in their pride they were
scattered all around the world and had
they just put themselves at the foot of
Calvary on their knees they would have
actually been the inheritors of a far
greater
uh gift to to become children of God you
know uh Satan here in this story is just
he's motivated out of Charity and love
for mankind Satan is by definition
devoid of Charity what really happened
is and in the traditional telling Satan
is envious of man why is he envious of
man some say he's envious of God's power
I don't think maybe that's some of it
but he's also envious of man because man
is is made lower than the Angels he's
fleshy the the the cartoon gets it right
in the beginning they say angels are
pure Spirit yeah that's true and man is
made lower than the Angels but in the
Incarnation when God becomes flesh and
dwells Among
Us that Incarnation elevates man above
the angels and Satan couldn't stand that
which is why he hates man and tempts man
is is constantly trying to devour our
souls including through silly little
cartoons that are now appearing on
Amazon nothing new it's been the story
for all of history my favorite comment
yesterday is from Leon mikad 4748 who
says anyone could have had a great 45%
if they had Democrats voting for them in
the GOP Primary as well Nikki Haley is
only in there to do as much damage as
possible before eventually dropping out
I totally disagree with this I totally
disagree I I see your point you're
saying Nikki Haley is more liberal than
Trump or Nikki haly is the more moderate
yeah yeah that's obviously
true but not every candidate could get a
bunch of Dems to vote for her in a
primary Ronda santis couldn't do that
probably that that was always desantis's
problem in the race is Nikki Haley is
running in the anti-trump lane and she
can credibly position herself as an
anti-trump figure who attracts never
Trump who attracts some moderate
Democrats who attracts The Establishment
GOP D santis could never do that because
because all of those groups I just
mentioned hate Donald Trump and they
hate Ronda santis a little bit less but
they still hate him because he's kind of
like Donald Trump and because he's
wielded power effectively in Florida so
Nikki actually pulled off a a pretty
impressive political maneuver there by
being able to consolidate all of that
support I don't think she's just in it
to cause as much trouble as possible I
think she's in it because she has no
incentive to drop out I don't think she
has a path to Victory she as she's
currently running her campaign is
certainly not representing the
conservative wing of the party she is as
she must representing the other wing of
the party but I think she's going to
stay in until she runs of money and
stops raising her name recognition and
stops galvanizing support and stops
setting herself up for for a future
political career as the opponent to
trumpism or or at least having a lot of
speaking tours and sitting on a lot of
corporate boards and none of that's
happening right now she is she is only
winning on all of those fronts she'll
only get out when there's an incentive
to do it and it's not happening
yet now speaking of nothing changing on
the
left John Stewart is returning to the
Daily
Show I barely remember when John Stewart
took over The Daily Show I just
mentioned uh watching South Park as a
kid in the 90s in the 90s Comedy Central
was a very small TV channel and South
Park was this Juggernaut that really
made it a big deal and there was another
show that was pretty big for Comedy
Central standards not compared to South
Park but but by the standards of this
cable network which was The Daily Show
and it was hosted by Craig kilborne and
it was a funny show and then John
Stewart took it over in 99 or
something and he made it a big deal not
really among viewers but among the media
the ratings were always relatively low
for the Daily Show but the right kind of
people watched it people who were
working in the media would watch it and
so he got way outside press coverage he
had a way bigger influence on politics
it became a real cultural phenomenon I
watched that show a bunch when I was a
kid he's very funny comedian John
Stewart and then he created all these
spin-offs the Steven coar show and John
Oliver and all these other people and it
was it it had a lot of influence and
then the moment John Stewart left that
show it completely went to pot no one
really talked about it anymore they gave
the show to Trevor Noah he was a total
flop in that position now I don't even
know who the host is I think they just
have a a rotating cycle of hosts and and
now he's back he's coming back as an
executive producer of the show and he's
going to host the show one night a week
why why do I care again I not that not
even that many people watched it back
when it was a big popular
show the significance of this story is
that it reminds
us the Democrats have nothing new the
Democrats have nothing exciting to look
forward to the Democrats the Liberals
broadly peaked in the late 2000s that
was Peak popular lib Democrat American
politics end of bush everyone's angry at
Bush Obama's coming up he's a good-look
guy and he's the first black president
and he gives speeches that impress some
people not me but some people and yeah
wow Hing change and none of that worked
out and Obama said he wanted to
fundamentally transform America because
obviously he hates America you don't
want to fundamentally transform
something that you love so he succeeded
largely in doing that and since then
it's all been on the decline since then
you had Obama Obama's economy was still
terrible he divided the country he did
win re-election but then just after
Trump you had a huge reaction or just
after Obama you had a huge reaction
against him in the form of Donald Trump
uh the left has not
recovered how could they what's their
new idea we're going to flood the
country with more illegals we're gonna
We what's the new idea we're going to
oppose War what are you talking about
Barack Obama bombed more countries than
George Bush
did the world order got much shakier
under Obama than it did even under Bush
well we're going to we're going to stop
you know just subsidizing the rich what
are you talking about Democrats are the
party of the Rich and Republicans are
the party of deplorables and
irredeemables and bitter clinging white
trash that you all absolutely condemn
and have nothing but disdain for well
yeah okay that's true well we're the
we're the what we're the what you got
nothing you got nothing guys and so the
best they can do is is drag this poor
man out of retirement and put him back
in The Daily Show chair and try to
recapture the magic magic's gone baby so
because they're not going to get that
spark back the only thing the Democrats
can do is tighten their grip on power
when you have a popular political
movement and you have cohesion and you
have a Clear
Vision you can afford a looser grip on
power because people just all kind of
know what they're doing and they just
naturally do it and they go in the right
direction and they vote for the
candidates you want them to vote for and
they support the policies you want them
to support when the ruling class and the
people are at odds with one another and
increasingly at odds then the ruling
class has to tighten that grip on power
they have to erect all sorts of fences
around the capital and around the White
House and meanwhile they're tearing down
the fences at the southern border which
is part of the reason the people hate
the leaders in charge or at the very
least we're very frustrated with them
you got to start arresting Midwestern
Granny's for taking selfies on January 6
the worst day ever you got to start
throwing the leader of the opposition
into prison you got to start Prosecuting
him you got to start sending federal
troops down to the Border to stop States
from exercising their constitutional
right to protect
themselves you got you got to really
tighten that grip on Power and we're in
January of 2024 okay we're in January
and there are four prosecutions against
the leader of the opposition and Joe
Biden is contemplating sending the Army
in to physically remove the Texas
National Guard and open up a pathway for
foreigners to invade what day is it it's
January
25th we we got 10 more months of this
this before the
election and we've got 11 more months in
the
year there is no sign that any of this
is going to loosen up we hit our first
constitutional crisis Before the War
Began the prosecutions we had our second
constitutional crisis in the first month
of the year can you
imagine what the next months hold now
speaking of the Democrats tightening
their grip you know there's a guy
running
against Joe Biden on the Democrat side
I'm not talking about Bobby Kennedy he's
running as an independent now not even
talking about you know Maryann
Williamson or some of the other fringey
candidates this's a guy Dean Phillips
Democrat congressman running against Joe
Biden right now in a primary and he
theoretically could get some votes you
know Dean Phillips is a guy who's voted
with Joe Biden 100% of the
time and yet thinks Biden's not the man
for the job right now so he's just
running to say hey I want to give
Democrats an alternative
and the Democrats will not let this guy
get his name out there the Democrats in
no way will let this guy get a fair
shake and in fact the court has admitted
to at the democrat's request that the
the Democrats have every right to rig
their primary so this wasn't even
recently six years ago seven years ago a
federal judge William zock dismissed a
lawsuit against the DNC made on behalf
of Bernie Sanders against whom uh
supporters alleged the DNC rigged the
primary CU they did and the the DNC won
the the court said yeah the party has
every right to rig its own
primaries and it it does the party picks
the nominee we think that it's the
people who pick the nominee it's the
party that picks the nominee and then
the people are supposed to pick the
president though I'm not sure that that
always happens the Democrats have always
been a little more inclined to
wheelpower that's why they have
mechanisms like superdelegates in their
party that's why they have ways for
party bosses to maintain more control
over that well the Democrats control the
government and they're going to bring
that philosophy Republicans still have
this philosophy that people and States
should have more control and we should
recognize subsidiarity and federalism
and local control and Democrats have no
sense of that and as they lose as they
lose popular support on basically every
issue they are going to bring that
tightened grip philosophy to bear on
every level of power that they control
which is basically all of them now some
people are fighting back at the state
level including my guest in the mem
segmentum that would be Oklahoma state
senator Dusty ders who is proposing
outlawing porn punishing it and also
punishing people who send adulterous
sexs to one
another I think this is terrific the
rest of the show continues now you don't
want to miss it become a member use code
n kws at check out for 2 months free on
all annual
plans
[Music]
a